So, finally, I just want to
talk about a couple of issues
that you'll always face
when you're doing tracking.
So the first one is initialization.
How do you start the thing?
And there's no good answer.
The examples I showed you
before were done manually.
Somebody says, oh, track that.
Okay?
So you draw a little ser, you say,
keep track of that thing.
You might have a background
subtraction method.
Okay, so every now and then, you may
be able to subtract that background,
find the objects.
And say okay, keep track of that
object because it's isolated.
And I'm going to track it as it
moves along even when it becomes
like partially occluded or, or
with other moving things in the way.
Or, you might have a detector that can
detect things when they're clear and
fully visible, right?
So I've got a a bank robber detector.
No.
I, I might have a particular
car detector and it'll say, oh,
a jeep has just shown up.
Follow that jeep.
So the detector is running, and
it'll only fire sometimes, when it
gets a good, clear view of something.
But then you want to track and
follow it through.
Next question is where do you get your
sensor and your dynamics models from?
Well we've talked
a little bit about this,
your dynamics models you maybe can
learn by essentially from real data.
That's generally pretty hard.
Because if you could track the real
data without the dynamics model,
you wouldn't be using
the dynamics model.
So, you might use it from clean data.
Remember we talked about
the girl jumping in front of
the black background?
That would be some clean data.
Or it says here you might
specify domain knowledge.
That means you're,
like, the smart person.
You just write down what it is.
Or you take another trip to Delphi, and
you get another thing from an oracle.
Now, for the observation model,
typically, it says generative
observation model.
What that means is,
remember we did the, the model for
the robot sensing distance.
So if I knew the,
the wall was three meters away.
And I take some measurements.
And, I collect them and
I get a distribution.
Now I know what my
distribution would be.
The trick is, I had to know that the
thing was actually three meters away, or
two meters away.
Right, I have to know the ground truth.
So you have some sort of
absolute sense or measurement.
Prediction versus correction,
remember this whole thing
about tracking and inferences.
I make some prediction, I take some
measurements, I do my correction.
The question is,
what's that relevant trade-off?
Remember we talked about
this in Kalman filter,
which basically came down to what's
the relative size of the noise of my
measurements versus
the noise of my process.
Actually, we usually do
it the other way around,
the noise of my process versus
the noise in my measurements.
If one is too strong,
you'll ignore the data.
If the other is too strong,
you'll ignore the predictions.
So getting those balanced right
is just a little bit of magic
that you have to do based
upon looking at the data.
Here's a more interesting or
I should say fundamental one and
it's referred to as data association.
Data association basically
is what if we don't know
which measurements to
associate with which tracks?